en el vídeo de medianas de un triángulo
y centro hoy de hice la prueba de que el
centro hoy de esta a dos terceras partes
de la distancia sobre la mediana yendo
del vértice al punto medio para probarlo
lo que hicimos fue pasar nuestro
triángulo de dos dimensiones a tres
dimensiones pues dije que las cuentas
salían más sencillas sin embargo alguien
mencionó en un comentario que sería
buena idea ver la prueba en dos
dimensiones así que eso es justo lo que
vamos a hacer en este vídeo bueno para
eso déjame trazar por aquí el eje x y el
eje y ahí está el eje x y el eje se va
entonces acá tenemos el eje y el eje x y
lo que vamos a hacer es tomarnos un
triángulo que tenga dos vértices sobre
el eje x uno digamos por acá y otro por
acá y el tercer vértice sobre el eje o
sea estamos suponiendo que su altura que
su altura queda aquí en el eje y va
bueno vamos a ponerle coordenadas a esos
tres puntos a este punto vamos a ponerle
el punto cero cero o sea vamos a suponer
que el triángulo tiene altura c vale
bueno a este punto de acá no voy a poner
con otro color digamos con
morado vamos a ponerle también
coordenadas no se pensemos que esta
distancia del origen a ese punto es ah y
entonces éste tendría tendría
coordenadas a 0 y finalmente vamos a
pensar que la distancia de este lado es
b no voy a poner en color azul que la
distancia de este lado es b entonces
este punto tendría coordenadas menos b
coma 0 nada más déjame dibujar el
triángulo para que se vea ya bien
entonces ahí tenemos nuestro triángulo y
cualquier triángulo se puede representar
así vale entonces nuestra prueba es
suficientemente general bueno entonces
lo que vamos a hacer es determinar las
coordenadas del centro pero para eso
primero necesitamos encontrar las
ecuaciones de las rectas que tienen a
las medianas y después interpretarlas y
bastará interpretar esas dos porque al
interceptar las pues ya la tercera
también pasa por ahí vale bueno entonces
empecemos encontrando las ecuaciones de
las medianas y para eso vamos a
necesitar estos puntos medios de acá
entonces déjame déjame poner este punto
medio aquí
en este punto medio aquí y este punto
medio acá entonces necesitamos las
coordenadas de esos dos puntos medios
bueno pues para encontrar la coordenada
de un punto medio de un segmento va
hasta encontrar el promedio de las
coordenadas de los extremos es decir
aquí tendríamos que hacer a 0 entre 2
nos quedaría a medios coma
0 entre 2,0 medios y lo mismo de este
lado hacemos 0 - b entre 2 que nos
quedaría menos b medios
coma 0 entre 2 o se hace
medios muy bien entonces ya tenemos las
coordenadas de este punto y de este
punto ahora podemos determinar la
ecuación de la recta que pasa por el
vértice y el punto medio empecemos
encontrando la pendiente déjame
dibujarla va a ser esta recta naranja de
acá entonces empecemos encontrando la
pendiente vale para encontrar la
pendiente hay que hacer la diferencia de
las coordenadas en que o se hace medios
menos 0 no lo voy a restar nada más lo
voy a dejar así entre a medios menos
menos b entre medios menos veces b
entonces va a ser más b pero de una vez
lo voy a poner como más 2 b entre 2 para
que ya tengan este denominador común
bueno ahorita podríamos sumar esto pero
en vez de sumar esta expresión voy a
multiplicar el numerador y el
denominador por 2 al hacer eso se
cancela este este y este y entonces ya
nos queda la expresión de la pendiente
como se / / a
2b muy bien entonces ya tenemos la
pendiente conocemos un punto entonces
podemos utilizar la fórmula de punto
pendiente para encontrar la ecuación de
la recta y esta fórmula lo que dice es
que es que tomamos la variable y le
restamos la coordenada en ya que
conocemos y eso de ahí es igual a tomar
x restarle la coordenada en x que
conocemos o sea sumar b y esto
multiplicarlo por la pendiente se
dividido entre a más 2 b muy bien
entonces ya tenemos la ecuación de la
recta que tiene a esta mediana de acá
bueno ahora vamos con la otra voy a
tomar este color como hueso supongo
entonces ahora vamos a encontrar la
ecuación de esta recta de acá para
entonces empezamos con la pendiente
misma idea la pendiente es tomar la
diferencia de las coordenadas en c
medios menos 0 otra vez nos queda se
medios en el numerador dividido entre b
medios menos b medios aquí hay un menos
hay que tener cuidado
- - bm dios - y entonces voy a ponerle -
bm dios - ah pero lo voy a poner como
menos 2a entre 2 ya tienen este
denominador común multiplicamos el
numerador y el denominador por 2 se
cancela este este y este y entonces la
pendiente nos queda igual al c dividido
entre menos b menos dos y muy bien ahora
usamos la fórmula de punto pendiente
para este punto de aquí y está pendiente
nos queda que ye - 0 - 0 es igual a x
menos a x menos ha multiplicado por la
pendiente por ser dividido entre menos b
-2 a esto está padrísimo ya tenemos
estas dos ecuaciones entonces ya
conocemos las ecuaciones de las rectas
así que nada más hay que interceptar las
para encontrar pues las coordenadas del
centro y de ba bueno pero justo
interceptarlas quiere decir igualar las
expresiones en por ejemplo
entonces tendríamos que igualar esta con
esta y vamos a ver que nos quedan vamos
a ver que nos queda de coordenada en x x
+ b x se dividido entre a más 2 b2b debe
ser igual a x menos a x men x c dividido
entre menos 2 b entre v menos 2 a entre
menos b menos dos años
bueno aquí podemos cancelar se conoce
porque se no es cero si se fuera a cero
tendríamos que el punto está aquí y no
sería un triángulo de adeveras no
tendría dos mil dos dimensiones entonces
pues vamos a cancelarse
ahora vamos a multiplicar cruzado está
para acá y está para acá y nos queda lo
siguiente voy a tomar el color blanco
nos quedaría x x x menos b -2 a menos b
- 2
luego multiplicar este por b o sea nos
quedaría menos b cuadrada menos 2 ave y
eso sería igual a multiplicar x por este
de acá a más 2 b2b y luego a más 2 b por
menos o sea menos a cuadrada menos 2 ave
hay menos dos aves de los dos lados los
cancelamos vamos a vamos a restar x por
a más 2 b y vamos a sumar b cuadrada de
los dos lados con la idea de de dejar
las x de un mismo lado y las constantes
de otro entonces restamos x x + 2 b y
sumamos b cuadrada aquí está se cancela
con esta está con esta esfera la idea y
nos queda lo siguiente a ver nos
quedaría x x menos b -2 b o sea menos 3
b -2 a menos a o sea menos 3 a es igual
a
ve cuadrada menos a cuadrado ve cuadrada
menos a cuadrado
déjame factorizar aquí un -3 entonces
tenemos menos 13 x x b menos a por ver
más a hay que ser cuidadosos ve más a es
igual a de menos a aquí es una
diferencia de cuadrados por b más
y de aquí podemos cancelar ve más a con
ve más a a no es igual a menos b porque
si no este punto sería igual este punto
y otra vez no tendríamos un triángulo
entonces podemos cancelar sin problema y
por lo tanto x nos queda igual a
dividimos entre menos tres de ambos
lados nos queda igual abm nos ha
dividido entre menos tres o bien a menos
b a menos b entre 3 entonces esto está
re bueno ya tenemos la coordenada en x
la coordenada en x de nuestro centro y
entonces déjame trazar aquí una
perpendicular para marcar que esto es la
coordenada en x entonces ya sabemos que
esto es a menos b entre 3 y esto nos
debería dar una pista de qué bueno sabes
que ahorita no te voy a contar mejor
vamos a seguir y hábitat vas a ver a qué
me refiero entonces ya tenemos la
coordenada x y con esta coordenada en x
podemos encontrar la coordenada en ye
sustituyendo en cualquiera de estas dos
vamos a hacerlo con esto con esto ya
casi de la derecha no importa cuál sea
cualquiera funciona entonces déjame
tomar el color azul
nos quedaría que en es igual a x - o sea
a b tercios menos a menos a x c / / /
menos b -2 a pero observa que menos a es
lo mismo que menos tres tercios entonces
al hacer al hacer esta resta nos queda a
menos tres a o sea nos quedaría menos 2
a menos b - b dividido entre 3 x c / /
menos b -2 a y b esto está padre este de
acá déjame agarrar el color cuál color
sería bonito agarras pues éste éste como
rosita entonces este menos 2 a menos b
se cancela con esteve menos 2 a y
entonces nos queda que la coordenada en
del centro y desigual hace
ce tercios entonces eso está muy bueno
aquí tenemos que la altura que la altura
de aquí acá es de tercios tercios o sea
la altura de aquí acá este tercios este
ángulo de aquí el recto entonces al
bajar una perpendicular corta en una
altura de tamaño de tercios vale
entonces ya tenemos las coordenadas del
centro que son a menos de tercios con
más de tercios y ahora podríamos
intentar utilizar la fórmula de
distancia pues así con con coordenadas
pero no voy a hacer eso ahorita de hecho
te invito a hacerlo por tu cuenta sin
embargo lo que voy a hacer ahorita es
algo que simplifica un poco las cuentas
y bueno no va a tener que utilizar la
fórmula de distancia sino un argumento
de semejanza va entonces ve lo que vamos
a hacer es lo siguiente déjame trazar la
mediana ahora desde este vértice de acá
entonces voy a agarrar este color como
rosa y voy a trazar la mediana desde
aquí como sabemos esa mediana esa
mediana también pasa por el centro hoy d
y llega acá el punto medio vale llega
acá al punto medio pero esta mediana
justo nos ayuda a construir dos
triángulos semejantes este de aquí
arriba con este de acá con este grandote
ahora lo que nosotros queremos mostrar
es que el centro y de esta a dos tercios
de la distancia es decir queremos ver
que este punto divide en razón uno a dos
o bien que esta distancia entre toda
esta de acá es más déjame ponerle
nombres a ver si alcanzan los colores
pero bueno queremos ver queremos ver que
esta distancia de acá le vamos a llamar
de entre la distancia total que déjame
llamarle l
/ l
rl es igual a dos tercios si logramos
probar eso ya terminaríamos pero ve
justo vamos a utilizar las semejanzas de
este triángulo con este de acá para
encontrar la razón de entre l o sea de
este lado entre todo este de acá observa
que estos dos triángulos son semejantes
son semejantes porque tienen este ángulo
en común el ángulo recto que que salió
justo de de trazar el punto para
encontrar la coordenada y este de acá
que también es recto porque es donde se
intersectan los ejes entonces tienen
este ángulo recto y este ángulo del
rector de aquí pero además tienen el
ángulo de aquí arriba en común el ángulo
entre la altura y la mediana entonces
estos dos triangulitos que aquí están un
poco apretados pero espero que se vean
bien estos dos triangulitos son
semejantes y como son semejantes las
razones de lados correspondientes tienen
que ser las mismas entonces vamos a ver
que nos queda de d entre l las razones
de las razones la razón de las
hipotenusa d
/ l d / l pues eso nos queda justo igual
a este cateto de aquí entre toda esta
distancia pero sabemos que este cachito
de aquí abajo s tercios entonces el de
aquí arriba este de aquí arriba
este de acá es dos tercios de ce es dos
tercios de c vale entonces esta razón de
entre l es igual a la razón de dos
tercios de c dividido entre el total
mientras el total que es c y esto de
aquí es igual a dos tercios entonces con
esto terminamos con esto logramos
mostrar que de entre el este entre éste
es igual a dos tercios y eso es justo lo
que queríamos y bueno a partir de eso
pues ya podemos decir varias cosas
porque si sí de esos dos tercios del
total de la distancia entonces él es un
tercio y por lo tanto se mide el doble
de él y así el centro y de parte de la
mediana en razón uno a dos o bien si
quieres dos a uno
bueno entonces esta de aquí es la prueba
en el plano es una prueba en dos
dimensiones y con esto ya tenemos dos
pruebas una en tres dimensiones donde
las coordenadas quedando un poco más
sencillas y esta de acá esta de acá que
es en dos dimensiones que tuvimos que
hacer un poco de analítica encontrar
intersecciones de rectas y algunas otras
cosas que tienen que ver con cuentas
pero afortunadamente al final no nos
salvamos de encontrar la distancia
utilizando un argumento de semejanza
vale entonces esa fue la idea de la
prueba y también te invito a que tú la
termines utilizando la fórmula de
distancias pero bueno independientemente
de todo esto este resultado es bien útil
el centro hoy de esta a dos tercios de
la distancia aparte de la mediana en
razón 1 a 2 y ese resultado lo vamos a
utilizar en otros vídeos para resolver
algunos problemas